Carlos castañas es uno de los tantos
chavistas que hoy se siente decepcionado
el gobierno revolucionario al que tanto
apoyó lo desalojó de la propiedad que
cuidaba desde hace 25 años tras el
fallecimiento de sus sueños ahora vive
en una habitación en precarias
condiciones
me sacaron de ahí engañado diciéndome
que me iba a que me iba a dar una casita
que me iban a dar aunque sea un
kiosquito y no me lo dieron además de
estar sin una vivienda digna Carlos
tampoco cuenta con recursos para
adquirirlas esta básica como el 81% de
la población su pensión apenas alcanza
los 7 dólares
hago una sola comidita en el oeste de
Caracas Gregorio Velázquez Vocero del
Consejo comunal de la parroquia de Santa
Rosalía se encarga de organizar a los
habitantes del barrio para resolver sus
necesidades hoy también está a cargo de
promover la movilización para homenajear
Hugo Chávez para conmemorar la fecha que
se fue nuestro comandante aunque aún es
un chavista orgulloso está consciente de
que el a través de una crisis económica
que afecta a todos por igual sabe que ha
habido fallas pero aún así no culpa al
gobierno ni a la revolución bolivariana
los problemas económicos hay en
Venezuela son responsabilidad de el
Imperio del modelo capitalista
a diez años el fallecimiento de Hugo
Chávez su proyecto socialista no logró
erigirse como fue concebido para este
analista político Nicolás Maduro está
creando un nuevo modelo donde se
contemplan los valores del capitalismo
para conectar con otros sectores de la
sociedad ya se habla de dólar claramente
ya no se habla tanto del Bolívar
soberano como tal la moneda nacional
ahora se habla incluso de este banca
digital o criptomonedas eso era
impensable en la época de Chávez cada
cinco de marzo se le rinde homenaje al
fallecido presidente y algunos de sus
más cercanos aliados ya no conmemoran
con el gobierno porque no forman parte
del círculo de poder para la victoria
siempre hermano en seremos seguidores
como Gregorio intentan mantener su
legado vivo pero la corrupción y las
promesas incumplidas han llevado a la
decepción a muchos como Carlos que
esperaban más del proyecto socialista